[Music]
good morning John it's Black Friday and
Katherine and I have come to the mall in
order to attempt to not buy things now I
know what you think it's really kind of
a strange strategy to try and not buy
things by going to the mall but it is
probably the most interesting place to
not buy things because you get to look
at all the people who are buying things
and what they're buying and why so far
have been pretty unsuccessful in this
attempt to not buy things because I came
without a tape and so I had to go to
RadioShack and buy a mini DV tape but
that is the only thing that I'm gonna
buy I promise as our first
accomplishment in our attempt to go to
the mom and not buy things Catherine is
actually coming out money positive as
she just found $28 on four of the
bathroom stall and we're keeping X now I
can't deny that people are looking at me
weird but I'm looking at them weird too
so I'm coming in to wash have you ever
been in overcoming and Fitch cuz I had
never gotten ever cut me in physical for
today and oh my god I thought it was
with a popular people shop is it is it a
gay store I don't mean gay in the
derogatory way that people sometimes use
it nowadays cuz that is not cool gay
synonymous with lame like can you think
of a worse insult no I mean gay like
homosexual there are men and no clothes
all over the walls doing this how is
this the popular person store it's the
gay person store seriously my mind is
made up
Abercrombie & Fitch is gayer than both
Claire's and the beef stick stand anyway
John I didn't go to the mall to make fun
of Abercrombie & Fitch though that was a
wonderful perk I went to the mall to try
and sort out some of my feelings about
Christmas John and over it I'm having a
really hard time caring about Christmas
I don't think I'm alone it's as if we
all get a bunch of time off of work so
that we can be even more stressed out
finally we have some time in which we're
not churning away making money and now
we get too freaked out about trying to
spend it all does this sound like a
horrible idea to anyone else
so that's really mostly why we went to
the mall I wanted to see the people
spending all of their money so that I
could understand but I still don't
understand you know how I feel about
money I like having it I hate spending
it so
Christmas is obviously contrary to the
way that I behaved but I just want to
say to people
family and friends and fun have nothing
to do with stuff stuff and stuff people
love you people love me the people that
love us don't want our money they want
our time they want to know we care and
buying something for someone doesn't
work anymore I think that in America now
we don't want more stuff I don't want
more stuff I want less stuff I don't
want your money
I don't want your stuff I want you time
and that's what I want to give people
this year instead of working my ass off
trying to make more money so that I can
give people more stuff I'm gonna cut out
the middleman and I'm just gonna give
people in my time here's my time it's
for you John it's for you nerdfighters
it's for all the people that I love in
the world
just ask I'll give it to you I did have
trouble not buying a pretzel though and
also I wanted this moose head John we'll
see you tomorrow
sorry no scavenger hunt clue today I
have no excuse